always remember the universe has a way
of leading into where you're supposed to
be at the moment you're supposed to be
there let's do this
it took me 20 years to find you how many
people can say that
you are the best-kept secret in the
universe and I found you
which makes me perfect for this job you
really think a black suit it's going to
solve all your problems
no but looks damn good on you we are
[Music]
recognizable only as deja vu and
dismissed just as quick a time to prove
yourself agent M we may have a problem
in London welcome to MI beam you will be
with Asian Paints one of the best ever
to ever suit
[Music]
catching up on my daily meditation time
for lunch ah thank you hungry
it's 9:30 it's Tuesday's taco day we've
been compromised is every citizen of
this planet at risk
[Applause]
if you could all just look right here
just try
gonna be fun left fun with it
there should be a big red button around
here somewhere found it we are the men
in black
looks like a tables of 10 go I was
incredible
you